we're told this network diagram
represents the different train routes
between three cities
each node is a city and each directed
arrow represents a direct bus route from
city to city
so for example
this arrow right over here i guess would
represent a direct bus route that starts
in city three and ends in city one
while this arrow that has an arrow on
both sides shows a route that both
starts in city 3 and ends in city 1 and
a route that starts in city 1 and ends
in city 3.
so it says complete the matrix so it
represents the number of direct routes
between the cities where rows are
starting points and columns are end
points so this is the matrix right over
here i encourage you if you feel so
inspired and i encourage you to feel so
inspired pause this video and see if you
can fill out this matrix right over here
you have nine entries in this matrix for
each of these combinations between the
starting city and ending city
all right now let's do it together so
what would go here this would be the
number of direct routes that start at
city one and end at city one
so if we start at city one
are there any things that then end at
city one
well no it doesn't look like there's
anything that starts at city one and
ends at city one so i will put a zero
there
what about this one right over here
well he's to start at city one and end
at city two
so let's see this starts at city one and
ends at city two so that's one
we get 2
and then we get 3
and then we get 4 because you can start
at city 1 here and then end at city 2.
so we get 4.
now how many start at city one and end
at city three pause this video and think
about that actually
all right we're going to start at city
one and end at city three
let me get another color out here so i
could start here and go on this route
and because this arrow ends at city
three so that's one
this middle one does not start at city
one and end at city three it goes the
other way around so i'm not going to
count that
this one right over here i can go either
way so i could start at city one and end
at city 3 because we have that arrow
there and those like those look like the
only two that start at city 1 and end at
city 3.
so that looks like go back to the
original color
two routes right over there
now what about starting at city two and
ending at city one
well if we start at city two and end at
city one these three over here all of
these start at one and end at two they
don't go the other way but this one on
top with the double arrows you can go
either way so you could start at city
two
and end at city one so there's one route
here
let's see start at city two end at city
two well i don't see anything that looks
like that for city two so this is going
to be a zero
and then starts at city two ends at city
three so starts at city two ends at city
three
this arrow doesn't count because this
starts at three ends at two not the
other way around so we get a zero there
as well
and then let's go to city three how many
start at three and end at one so start
at three and end at one so this two way
arrow you could you could do that you
could start at three
and end at one so that's one
then this one right over here starts at
three
and ends at one because we can see the
arrow points two one right over there
and then it looks like and actually this
one i've i have so much that i've
written here that i actually can't see
too well the original let me erase it
actually so i can make sure i'm seeing
things properly yep that one too
looks like so this one
i can do and then this one i can start
at city three and end at city one as
well so it looks like we have three pats
there
now start at city three end at city 2.
that one's a little bit more
straightforward that's that path there
so that is one and then starts at city 3
ends at city 3. well we have this one
right over here
that's the only one so i would put one
so there you have it we have filled in
this matrix
so which city has the most incoming
routes pause the video and think about
that
so the city with the most incoming
routes we can look at the cities that
are the end points
and so city one
has a total of zero plus one plus three
has four incoming routes
city two
has a total of four plus one five
incoming routes and city three has a
total of two plus zero plus one has
three incoming rounds so it looks like
this would be city two sorry yep city
two with five incoming routes which city
has the most outgoing routes well then
we would just look the other way
actually pause the video and think about
that
well looks like city one
has
six outgoing routes city two only has
one outgoing route i'm just adding up
along the row and city three has
looks like five outgoing routes so city
one with zero plus four plus two there's
a total of six routes that start at city
one and go out of the city so that is
city one
with six routes